I'm a Leo so I definitely arrived in  competition and being the best and  center of attention you know we wanted  all  [Music]  my teenage years been tough I reflect a  lot on the days I was bullied in primary  school struggling with basketball just  fitting in with my identity in Australia  so if I could go back and say something  to my younger self I would just say keep  pushing baby girl I try to live every  day being free try to do me and live my  truth every day where would I want to  where I play my game how I want to play  my game that's freedom to me I would  never have dreamt of being where I am  today I've lived so much and it's been  so amazing but what I want is just  discover what the world has to offer  this is so much more than I'm still  chasing that  [Music]